this is bismillah alhamdulillah Salam
alaikum peace be with you thank you for
tuning in to another episode of the Deen
show in this way of life this way of
life that was brought by all the
messages of God that called people to
nothing but goodness didn't leave out
anything in one's life a complete
complete blueprint and how a person
should live their life from A to Z
that's right and it didn't even leave
out our next topic that's right a
billion dollar industry that's not
really brought anything good though
produce a lot of money and has got a lot
of people addicted what is this you're
gonna have to sit tight for our next
topic that many people are gonna be
really amazed that we're even talking
about can we talk about this is this
something that we should shy away from
all this and more here on the D show sit
tight we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Salam alaikum alaikum Salaam like a
little peace be with you
peace be with you too now how are you
Imam I have no I'm doing good it's so
good to be with you thank you for
finding time to be with us now you're
the director of mental health can you
explain for our viewing audience what is
when people have mental issues they come
and see you what does this mean you you
explain to us well it's part of an
organization that I work at access
California Family Resource Center and
basically it's a holistic approach to
help people with your problems so we've
got different departments that's
immigration it is housing it is welfare
it is financial assistance but also all
these things can really press and they
can really generate a lot of emotional
stress on the individual or the family
so that holistic approach is can we help
people in their totality rather than
just take care of the housing but not
addressing their familial problems or
their emotional problems and people have
this impression that mental challenges
or mental health challenges are like
schizophrenia crazy people insane people
and the reality is there is just so much
emotions that can really be bothersome
and challenging to the individual a
person who does not have legal status
they can develop anxiety as a result a
person who's having a problem was their
loved ones a person were just relocated
from one place to another adjustment
issues sometimes it's just family
problems couples having issues with one
another so when we speak about mental
health we're not just talking about
people that need to be medicated we're
talking about people who are having
problems just because they're humans
that is just part of the challenge that
we have as as humans and they happen to
be in charge of that of that program
well mashallah that you find a time to
be with us here so before we dwell into
our topic I introduce the show and I
said look we followed this way of leiden
even mention the name alright because a
lot of times you know a person will be
so qualified for the job and then what
in the past you know the person had all
credentials but he was african-american
he didn't get the job so sometimes when
people here because they're a little bit
timid of this word and I'll say in in a
second but I want to define it it's a
way of life that was lived by all the
messengers of God including Noah Abraham
Moses Jesus peace be upon the Christ and
the last and final messenger problem how
Matt peace be upon him it's a way of
calling a human being to submit to the
one creator alone and to do good to
develop good and Noble character and it
doesn't shy away from anything but
sometimes I didn't even mention the word
yet when we mention it some people are
going to get a little timid a little bit
afraid but pornography it's addictive
and many people are under this hypnosis
spell and now it's corrupting homes
corrupting societies but is this
something that now is relevant in
slumbers Islam I said the word does
Islam now come and even address and and
and and we should be shy away from
talking about something like this well
let me just begin by appreciating you
addressing this topic Eddie and the
point being is that you could have
chosen a much safer topic to talk about
but the reality is the messengers were
sent in order to guide people and they
would address the challenges that the
masses are facing at this point so
pornography you said it was a billion
dollar industry it's a billion dollar
industry a month in the US every month
every month in the u.s. it's a billion
dollar industry
Wow so the 1 billion dollar is not
worldwide it's not annually its monthly
only in the US estimation annually it's
about fifty two billion dollars and with
technology it is probably going to jump
a lot more than that but then like you
said you know in your introduction you
said that this is a way of life from A
to Z and when we say it's a way of life
we're not talking about a way of life
that dictates but rather it's a way of
life that really disciplines it's a way
of life that guides and if you look into
the whole idea of Islam I mean one of
the most important pillars of what Islam
before Jesus and Moses and know
muhammad peace be upon Allah peace be
upon all of them taught is this whole
idea of the subjugation of the passion
and that is teaching self control and
self discipline where the person is in
charge of what they become and who they
are rather the underway around having
their desires and their lusts and their
different emotions be out of control
producing who they become rather the
person being in charge of what their
destiny is going to be is going to be
like now Islam did not leave this out at
all it addressed it because it's a human
need in a way but it's a human need that
needs to be put in the proper channels
sexual passion you know so now we have
got this passion that God has created in
us and in Islam we are encouraged to
enjoy that but enjoy do not abuse enjoy
by putting it into the proper channel
and the proper channel is that you must
be in an ethical relationship adding
that ethical value to the relationship
that you are in and that would be where
you direct your sexual energy now
someone says you know okay
Islam calls to moderation right not
going to extremes and someone says you
know what I just want to watch it a
little bit to get my relationship with
my wife to boost it up a little bit you
know what I mean I'm not gonna take it
anywhere else I'll keep it with my wife
and we'll just do this part-time we'll
watch this and have you heard this
excuse yes I have and that is part of
the what the industry uses but you have
got to remember one thing
porn is somebody else's imagination it
is not my imagination and it is not you
know a wife's imagination this is
somebody else imagination and they're
selling it to us but see remember this a
healthy sexual relationship between
husband and wife is not developed would
not be enhanced or enticed because you
know they're watching porn that is not
how you enhance the sexual relationship
between between partners so what we
would do is there is actually a better
alternative than watching and watching
porn and you know I mean we will talk a
lot more about the
but what we see on porn is usually what
really happens um in there but I've
heard that argument and it's a really
bad argument it's you know like you know
what I am not really going to become
alcoholic I just want a little alcohol
and Islam closes the door completely on
that in the Hadees as you well know the
prophet sallallaahu salam says mascara
Kesava callaloo haram that which makes
you intoxicated in in large quantities
small quantities of it are forbidden so
now because it has got that potential
then there is really no amount that
would be considered to be a safe amount
salam cuts it from the root by all means
if it doesn't contribute to the
betterment of society it's out by all
means and the idea is very simple it has
got that potential into it can
potentially lead there therefore there
is really no goodness that can come out
of it now to be honest there may be some
goodness coming out of it but the harm
always outweigh the goodness and at that
point whatever goodness may come out of
it it's not worth it
we're gonna take a break and be right
back with more here in the Dean show you
will not feel a woman do not kill a
child do not you know going to different
religiously Buddhism in Division forms
of Christianity I even ran into people
from the nation of the slap feeling very
mad you will not feel an animal you will
not cut a tree down
do not turn into water do not burn their
homes
[Music]
back here on the Dean show with shake
Yossef as agha now I also when I open up
the show I kind of defined what this
beautiful way of life is the way that's
calling you to noble behavior is calling
you to establish a direct connection
with the one who created you is calling
you to be good to your neighbor to be
good in society but now a lot of people
they have attributed this maybe you know
to the actions of a few bad apples and
there are a few bad apples in every
Bunch so now for the person who likes
what we have to say but because we cater
to a lot of the I call not yet Muslims
because everyone has the potential to
submit just to the one God the same God
that Jesus worship that's the guy that
we're worshiping and we're trying to
develop ourselves to be the best human
beings that we can but someone's
listening to you and now we mentioned
the word Islam and they right away think
man look at these terrorists I don't
want to take nothing from it we got to
say to this person so we can remove the
block and continue on with that topic
and well we first thank them for
watching by the way and I think that is
and that is really beautiful and one
thing that has happened as a result of
the bad apples that is we kept defining
Islam by what it's not so we're
constantly talking about all Islam is
not terrorism Islam is not violence it's
not extremism it's not this so we talk
about what it's not but rarely do we get
a chance to talk about what it is and
you know part of what Islam teach here
is this idea of the subjugation of the
passion the idea of self-discipline that
is part of the teachings universal
values that some appreciates that
actually anybody you don't even have to
be a Muslim to appreciate you know some
people talking about let us protect our
families porn is not good to the family
let us protect about our young boys
about you know our young girls we're
talking about the first time that a
person is exposed to porn as we talk
right now is at the age of 11 11 at the
age of 11 so much sexual content is
coming towards this kid beat a boy or
bit a girl that they have not developed
yet and they don't know how to contend
with the information that they're just
bombarded with
and that you know what don't need to be
a Muslim you don't need to be a
Christian or Jew or atheist or theist in
order to appreciate you know what the
need to protect you know our families
and our children from from that so I
would say to the people who are watching
out there you know what you may not
agree with my theology you may not you
know appreciate my face but the point is
that this is an issue that is impacting
the masses and that is you know as a
Muslim community this is what we like to
contribute out there now the person says
also another argument someone says look
I'm not harming nobody just me myself
and the video and I'm having a good time
I'm not murdering nobody I'm not
stealing from nobody what's the problem
actually that is not a very good
argument this is like the person who
says that
I'll drink I will not drive I'll just be
at home harm don't to self is harm done
to society harm done to self is harm
done to society okay you may not be you
know driving out there causing accidents
you know getting your DUI but it's
taking away from the potential of a
father that you can be it's taking away
from the potential of a good husband
that you can be it's taken away from so
much potential of you as an individual
that you can bring into society so this
is really not a good argument because I
am not harming anybody else therefore it
should be okay that is not acceptable
and by the way if you are in a
relationship then you are harming
somebody else okay because you are
leaking and misdirecting your sexual
energy where it does not belong now III
heard this quote from a spokesman that
was against pornography and can you
comment on this saying that the
addiction of porn is far more serious
than addiction of crack cocaine you know
actually hey that is not um that was
actually made out to the Congress to the
Congress yes that that quote was made
into Congress and the argument is very
simple and that is crack and cocaine you
can actually detoxic eight the body from
it there might be a time when your body
is really cleansed from the remnants of
crack cocaine sexual images are so
printed in our heads that getting rid of
it almost is next to impossible so would
you say this would contribute now to a
person having these images and now going
out and harming an innocent woman
someone who's walking down the street he
just saw a porn video and then he goes
and acts out on us that is actually not
a good argument no there is no
correlation between let's say rape child
molestation sexual assault on people
simply because a person is addicted to
porn that is not the problem that we
have was porn you had this at this point
it is the fact that it is addictive it
is costing money but then again look
into the bigger picture and the kind of
image that it sells to us as to
definition of manhood and womanhood a
man is now his manhood is determined by
the size of his penis by how good he is
by how much pain he is able to inflict
on the woman and now that stud that is
good but reality is can you imagine if
this is how we were to go around
defining manhood or objectifying women
the way that porn does or the whole idea
of institutionalizing um racism simply
because a person belongs to a certain
ethnic background therefore we can say a
lot more about his private parts so it's
not just the sex or what appears to be
sex there is the objectification of
women that is taking place there is
racism that is taking place and there is
just the manipulation of these young
minds that are out there in cheating
them defining what is manhood and what
is womanhood from watching us would you
say also that the man would also have
more of a now less of respect towards
the average woman from watching this
looking at her just like you know a
piece of meat just you know someone
who's not respected after watching her
with men so many times on the screen
that he just has his passion that he
just wants to fulfill this lustful
desire you know now he starts even not
having much of a desire towards his own
wife there is um actually a woman her
name is Gayle dance she wrote a book
called Portland and what she has
is that she has analyzed the porn
industry out there and what we see
happening is um the whole idea of how
women are disrespected in porn because
there is usually no sexual pleasure that
is taking place especially in art core
porn it is all about how much pain can
you inflict on the woman how much can
you make her scream you know older and
and I don't mean to be graphic you but
like you said you know this is we're
addressing an issue that is impacting
the masses you know can you rupture
discs and Europe sure that and the whole
point is it's all about impacting us on
inflicted as much pain as possible so
the disrespect is you know to the whole
sexual act that is taking place that's
supposed to be very enjoyable between a
man and a woman but now it is a source
of pain to one party and the other party
is seen as a person who can inflict most
pain on the on the woman our women are
presented as people who are always
looking for it
craving for it and they just enjoy the
pain that is inflicted upon them because
of what the men are doing to them
and when a young man sees this no TV
does not only sell us products TV also
sells us ideas it's else's ideas about
who we are and it sells us ideas about
the people who are around us and who
they are and what TV makes out of them
well this from viewing porn with this
would you from any studies with this
help in preserving marriages or does it
contribute to the divorce rate going up
you know it's it's really sad Eddie and
you know in the capacity of a therapist
and I see many clients Muslims as well
as non-muslims the sadist is when you've
got a couple that walks into the office
and the man is looking down say well
what brought you in today and the wife
would say my husband is addicted to porn
and say you know what I feel like he's
cheating on me I cannot compete with the
women that he sees on porn and the worst
of it yet is there is nothing that I can
to stimulate my husband what porn does
is that it kills the natural stimulants
in a man women are naturally beautiful
they are naturally seductive they're
just naturally stimulating to a man but
what has happened is that the person who
is addicted to porn has become so
decent-sized that his own wife is saying
I cannot excite my husband anymore and I
feel like I have really lost I cannot do
what these women are doing and because
he's taking me for granted and he's
gotten so used to me
he needs to be excited by different
means and I am unable to do what he sees
on porn these are amazing facts
hopefully people can watch this and
start to develop a change for the better
leaving off this can we call it just
pure evil it is pure evil yeah and and
go towards more good and that's we're
inviting people to goodness and good
things and we'll be back with more here
on today's show sit tight
[Music]
[Music]
I am Not Afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid
iserlohn Dios halal solo ya na seuk
lesson I would go to my room
lock the door go straight and car thank
God you know me better than myself show
me the right way and I will not look too
I will leave everything behind a lot of
that greater and he creates everything
intelligent back here in the Deen show
with Sheikh Yasser fours Agha
now as human beings we know that most of
us you know the vast majority of people
they reflect upon the creation and they
know that look you know this all
couldn't just come by chance design
indicates a designer so for those people
who want to live by the game plan that
was originated by the one who created
them if we are God conscious people
people who want to get close to the one
who created us is this a way that can
bring us by watching this being involved
in this in any way is this pleasing or
displeasing totally to the one who
created us well as far as Islam is
concerned there is really no there is
really no room for argument it's done it
is it is it is extremely evil
so if you got a wife and husband or you
by yourself there's no excuse for this
no they're not not not at all how about
self pleasure in Islam itself pleasure
well it depends well what do you mean by
self pleasure yeah okay but remember
Porter does not really give you it gives
you a very momentary self pleasure and
like I said you know I don't want us to
be graphic here but what happens is that
porn decent Assizes yeah and and here is
a sad fact you know what soft porn the
stuff that we watch on TV is becoming so
unbelievably hardcore in such a way that
the porn industry is now competing with
what we see on regular TV because
regular TV is just getting really bad so
now a regular TV is becoming our soft
porn that is available to everybody out
there but then you get you
to that so what happens is that we need
to you know because of the excitement is
gone we need to come up with other
creative ways so that is why for example
I come from California and we've got the
San Gabriel Valley and that is the
biggest port industry in the world where
they make about 15,000 movies a year Wow
that's just in San Gabriel Valley there
is a website of porn dedicated to porn
website that comes up every 39 minutes
at every given minute
there are 29,000 people searching for
porn on daily basis it is 68 million
people looking for porn now the sad fact
is that a hundred and sixty thousand of
this is people looking for child porn so
what happens is it has really killed the
natural stimulants in a person so now we
need to find other ways to excite that
person so what would be exciting well
you know after a while it just gets to
be all the same because there is really
that so what you do is that you become
creative but in that creativity where
you're trying to solicit new viewers or
keep the ones that you have what you get
add is in two grounds where it is not
acceptable they have that the PCP now
out of the PC P which is the pseudo
child pornography and this was actually
a case that was brought by Congress
against the porn industry and that is
you cannot use children in porn because
that is illegal that would be considered
child rape and molestation so what the
porn industry has done two things they
bring these young people who are age
wise they are legal but looks-wise they
have got the faces and the bodies of
people who are minors so they would
advertise it as barely legal and again
this is to solicit people would actually
take a joy out of watching child porn
and the other thing that they did is
that they animated children in these
apps and actually the it was at the
Supreme Court said that said that was
legal because you're not using real
humans that at that point
so they refer to this as PCB pseudo
child porn and yet that is very that's
becoming popular amongst the people so
what can a person do you talked about
and briefly we're almost out of time
talk to us about the five principles and
then towards the end I heard you mention
that that very very important one that
we're talking about subjugation of one's
passions so can you start from number
one and get to number five and then how
can a person really develop control over
one's desires to leave off this evil
vice you see why by the end of the day
you know Muslims speak about you know
the five the five pillars and the five
articles of faith and all that but by
the end of the day we are really after
five principles by which a person is to
govern their life and that is
emphasizing and ascertaining the oneness
of God recognizing that there is a
creator out there and that creator has
given us the blueprint that you have the
spoken about the second one is the
subjugation of passion be in control
over your passion rather than being
guided by your passion or being guided
by your lust and your desires
number three is the whole idea that you
develop that good character about about
about the self there's a you know
Electra that we have on the 60s of
character developing a person's own
character but then again the person owns
character can only manifest itself in
how we act around those who are around
the people who are around us so that is
becoming a source of benefit to mankind
and especially for our Christian friends
who are watching us out there that is
actually the motto of Jesus peace be
upon him when he said well any Mubarak
and in a McCune and he made me a man of
blessings wherever I may be and we do
all of this being God conscious so these
would be the five principles by which we
want to lead our lives so any closing
comments or suggestions for the person
who's addicted to this and he's having a
hard time getting away what suggestions
what advice do you have for him you know
I I would say and I thank you for saying
to him or her because porn is not only
an addiction of men but women are
addicted to it as well I say that there
is really hope and I'll say please do
get the help please get professional
help please see a therapist out there to
help you with the with the addiction and
remember you know simply because a
person is addicted to it it does not
necessarily automatically make that
person inherently bad but we would say
that at this point we are making poor
choices and there is a way of getting
rid of the poor choices by getting the
professional help out there thank you
very much again for being with us may
God Almighty the creator of law reward
you thank you and thank you for sitting
tight through another episode of the
Dene show and Islam that way of life
that I mentioned the beginning is
calling you to nothing but goodness to
strive and to struggle against a lot of
those evil inclinations that you might
have so to do a jihad yes right a jihad
a jihad against many of these things
that you want to do but aren't
necessarily good for you and watching
pornography is definitely something
that's not good
it's not good for you or society and if
you can't beat the evil that's within
yourself how you gonna beat the evil
that surrounds you that's right
aslam is something that is for the whole
of mankind and when you live it it's the
same way of life that Abraham lived
Jesus Christ Moses in the last and final
messenger the problem Hamid peace be
upon him and when you live this way of
life it produces good and then you can
live good in this like life and have the
best in the next life with paradise
that's right paradise and that's what
we're striving for and we hope to see
you next time here again on the Deen
show until then peace be unto you
you